Jay Gruden was relieved of his duties in
the midst of his sixth season there and
a beat writer for this team for the
Washington Post less carpenter kind
enough to join us for a few minutes here
in the Honda inside a report before the
team has a press conference to introduce
bill Callahan as the interim head coach
how are you doing les I'm doing great
how are you today I'm doing fine I think
we're all better than Jay Gruden unless
you think this is this a relief for him
what do you think yeah I don't know if
it's the end of the world for him I mean
it was starting to get bad last few
weeks I you know he's always kind of you
played that clip I saw a second ago of
him you know saying the key works you
know that's kind of in a line he's used
a couple times even late last year I
he's he's always tried to seem very
laid-back about things and kind of let
them come and go as they are which is
probably a pretty good way to handle
being coach of the Reds kids but I would
say that I yeah I think it's a bit of
relief the way things were coming down
the last few days that it got so did it
start with the drafting of Duane Haskins
I had Joel clot of Fox Sports a couple
Fridays ago just asking him if he was
surprised that Haskins had yet to start
because he and I worked together at the
draft and he was evaluating all the
quarterbacks then and his response was
well the the room was split when Haskins
was drafted and there's still a rift
with the team and this seems to be the
the final throes of all of that les yeah
maybe a little bit I think the final
throws are more Olin v no Jay did not
prefer to have to wait Haskins that was
not his quarterback I don't know how
much he necessarily didn't want him as
much as he didn't want a guy with 14
starts he wanted something with a little
more experience someone who could walk
in and kind of fit in their offense
better if they had to play him right
away and if you're gonna take the guy in
the first round
you're gonna play him right away so I I
think more that was Jay's hesitation I
don't know that necessarily the the
ownership was down on him because of
that or he was down on them because of
that I think this has been kind of
coming since Alex Smith got hurt Alex
kind of held a lot together here and
once he was down suddenly then they're
running in quarterbacks off the street
at the same time they went to two sets
of starting guards I mean it just it
just all kind of snowballed from there
and then you know in the offseason
Schneider brought in several established
defensive coordinators to meet with the
current defensive coordinator and Jay to
kind of decide well you know what can we
do here on the defense the you know kind
of the the subtext of that being well
maybe one of these guys would replace
the current defensive coordinator so I
can't believe that's that well with Jay
I you know I think the writing was on
the wall that this wasn't going to last
much longer anyway unless something
miraculous happened here okay so less
carpenter the Washington Post here in
the Honda inside a report and while
we're in the I guess the weeds of
Haskins here does that all of this give
credence to Dave gentlemen up in New
Jersey where he said that Daniel Jones
and his mind definitely would not have
been available had the Giants waited to
pick 17 that you think that's the
quarterback that Gruden would have been
pounding the table for I think Rudin
would have been pounding the table for
him yes whether they would have chosen
him there's another question and it gets
back to what we were talking about
before but yeah absolutely I think he's
a guy that a lot of teams liked more and
more I kind of asked around the league I
kind of get the sense that teams had
very high grades on him you know in part
because he was a long time starter at
Duke you know theyíve worked with David
Cutcliffe now also I think some of the
things he does as a quarterback kind of
matched what a lot of the systems are in
the NFL today so it could be a very good
fit Hopkins probably is a little more of
a project just because he's rar doesn't
mean it could be a really good NFL
quarterback it just means that there's
more development there so then what does
it mean for Haskins do you think at one
o'clock Eastern time for this press
conference we're gonna hear Haskins is
named as the starter against the Miami
Dolphins I would doubt that right now
right as of now you know only Bruce
Allen is listed as the as the speaker at
the press conference I don't know
Callahan will be there if they do name a
quarterback I I'm gonna guess it would
be more like on Wednesday and we'll have
to see they have an awkward situation
with Colt McCoy finally having come back
from injury he does know the offense or
can't change the offense that much but
at this point when you're owing 5 and
you have at Wayne Haskins you guy would
think you would want to use him and so
if he doesn't play now I assume he's
gonna have to play fairly soon well you
mentioned Bruce Allen's name les I'm
mandated to ask you the question I think
all Washington Redskins fans want me to
ask Bruce has been nothing but nice and
kind to me since I've ever met him at
the first owners meeting way back in the
day in 2003 and that was before his
10-year run with Washington that has
been just nothing short of a
disappointment
how does he remain in his gig less well
you have a lot of responsibilities here
and so I think Dan Schneider is very
tied to Bruce Allen you know probably
one of his biggest things beyond sort of
overseeing the football operations is
trying to get a new stadium here and
they're trying very hard maybe go back
to the old RFK site and in DC and
there's a lot of loopholes that kind of
I don't what the rights were here is to
say but there's a lot of issues because
it's federal parkland they have to be
navigated and so Bruce is sort of in
charge of the stadium
push I think there's you know obviously
the business side of the team he's in
charge of it as well so I don't know
that necessarily you just kick him out
of here I don't know that that Dan's
mindset right now okay so now the name
Lincoln Reilly's already all over the
place les what do you think I think you
start throwing out all the names
part of the reason to do this and I was
told initially that you're going back to
the summer that Dan Snyder was impatient
and you know basically that J had four
losses early in the season so kind of
the New York game last week was sort of
the target that you know at least was in
my mind and I think in some in the
organization as to win what Dan would do
this so one of the thoughts was if you
fire your throat early then you're in
kind of the lead for the next guy I
don't know if they would go for a
college coach or not another name to at
least consider she's interested is Nick
Saban because they have a fondness for
Alabama players they have several
Alabama players here so I you know those
are at least two college names that I
think you have to at least look at as
well as some professional names I you
know don't don't ignore the name Greg
Williams who was here the defensive
coordinator before I think that could be
a that could be a possibility on the
table as well as well as some other
current pro head coaches or former head
coaches and assistants and then there's
another guy out
working on fox doing college football
for whom Dwane Haskins threw 50
touchdowns last year in Urban Meyer are
you hearing that name to us I have not
heard any you know any college names
beyond a couple that we talked about but
that's not necessary you know I they're
just getting started in this process I
you know this came quickly I my my sense
of it is Ronald Reagan decision was made
until late last night or early this
morning so I think I think this is you
know still genuine find out that he was
going to be meeting these guys until
about I don't know sometime late late
last night were called in for a 5:00
a.m. you know meeting so you know who
knows I I think they're still putting
their lists together all right last one
for you've less carpenter Washington
Post you've been covering this team for
a couple years now and the question is
the Jay Gruden arrow if you will five
plus seasons here lies Jay Gruden's
Redskins head coaching tenure the eulogy
would be what he would be he's a bright
offensive mind who came in and had some
early success and in many ways was
derailed by injuries and bad luck now
whether high you know he had that much
to do with walk sometimes you know you
always control your own luck obviously
the record is his but when you when you
bring in a franchise quarterback like
Alex Smith and you think you haven't for
five years and something goes down and
when you have I think 23 players ending
the season on I are the last two years
each year they had 23 players and this
year they're already at 10 and there's a
couple other candidates sitting out
there for that I you know in some ways
that's incomplete either he was never
fully with his weapons the last three or
four years and I think what phthalic
Smith went down at that sort of they
never done with the hole from which they
could never take less really appreciate
it thanks for calling in well thank you
you gotta it's less carpenter the
Washington Post in the Honda inside a
report for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel 239 under rec TV
for free on VR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app